こんにちは はじめしゃちょー です
はい 大変 お待たせ致しました 今日 から 新 チャンネル スタートします！！！
（ぱちぱち）
ありがとうございます ありがとうございます ありがとうございます（手を合わせるはじめ）
（表情筋を鍛える ）
長かった
とっても長かった
もうなんか
いつから作ろうと思ってたんだろう
多分ねもう作ろうと思ってたのは　もう
去年とか去年からもうちょっと作ろうと思ってまして
まあ色々考えてどうしたら作れるのかなとか何をしたら良いのかなと かどんな人と
ハッ！
動画を、、、
どうへくしょいっ！！！
したら良いのかなとか
色々 考えながら
ええ、ようやくこの日を迎える ことになりましたっ
いやあああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああんんん
大変でしたぁぁ...ねー
う～ん♡、なんか 今まで ずっと もう 一人 で 動画撮ったり作ってきたりしてき たんで
まあそれを何か他の人とやるっていうのはすごい
なんか
不思議な気分というか難しかったん ですけど、まあちょっと色々右往左往 して 考え ながら まだ 未 完成 な ところも
ありつつも ええ　ようやく
チャンネルスタートすることができます
はい チャンネル名は！！！！
loading...
動画の概要欄のリンクから飛んで下さい
なんかそれらしい名前になっていると思いますがあってなんで作ろうかと思ったというと
あの
僕ううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううんんん
今 いろんな人に支えられてyoutubeをやっております友達とか後輩とか
あの東京 から 来てくれた、たなっちと か ほんと いろんな人と一緒に動画 を作っています はい
で 動画 外でもそいつらとすごい仲がよくてあの
めちゃくちゃ 実 は 動画外、動画外が今
楽しいんですよ
まあ遊びも含めたりなんか日常の会話 とかまあ　いろんなところで面白くて そいつらといると
で、そいつらといるところとかを
面白くて もったいないというか それ を動画にできれ ば一番いいかなと思って
どうすればいいんだろうと思った時　なんかそれを見せるところはこのチャンネルじゃないなと
思いました　うん
もうこのチャンネルは僕がしたいこと をただただするチャンネルで
良いんじゃないか☆
他の奴らとの　それをどうするかって言った時に
新チャンネルを作るべきなんだなと思って
あの〜新チャンネルを作るというところまで至りました
な の で あの 新 チャンネル の テーマ は
あの〜はじめしゃちょーが主役ではないというところでございます！
あぁ！！
主役じゃねえ！そうだね本当に面白い奴らに囲まれて　あのー
ぼかあ　幸せなんですけど
まあそいつらとまた何か新しいもの を作っていければいいなと思っております
たなっちいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいんん♡
は）いやあ　たなっちい
た）はい
は）どうだい新チャンネルは
た）新チャンネルのことについて俺が言うんですか
は）そう だ ね
た）俺もう新メンバーのことは言って、、、
は）いやまだバレてねえ☆
た）ああまだバレてないんすね
は）まだバレてねえ　大丈夫だ
た）まあ新チャンネル
は）うん
た）そうですね やっぱはじめさんの
た）周りにいて思うんですけど
は）うん
た）はじめさん の 周り って 結構 面白い人が本当に多くて
は）うんうん
(はじめ手を忍ばせる)
た）いやあなんか
た）この 人
た）の面白さっ見せたいなーって思う ことは本当に多々あって
は）おおお
は）彼らの良い部分というかあとはじめさんのあの動画撮ってない部分
は）うんうん
た）の普段の面白さというかそういうワイワイした
た）良い雰囲気な所を見せられたらなって
た）思いますね
は）そうだよね　こうなんかそれ見せるってとこが　まあ　はじめしゃちょーチャンネルじゃないって言う
た）うんうんうん
は）まあ ここはもう僕が今まで通り したいことを好き勝手やっていくとしてそれ以外の部分を
た）うん
は）それ以外の僕の周りの人をこの家で何が起こってるのか日々
は）ふっwwwそういうのを動画にできれば良いなと思って
は）新チャンネルを作りましたのであの本当僕以外の人が色々出てくると思うんで
は）あの是非僕の周りの面白いことを みんなに共有できればいいなと思っております
は）本当に全然ね この チャンネルと 雰囲気が違うと思うので是非是非その このチャンネルで味わえ ない
は）雰囲気とかも楽しんでいただけると嬉しいと思います！！！！
は）新チャンネルの概要欄下にあると思いますので是非そちらから見ていただけるとありがたいです！！！
（なぜだか痛がるたなっち）
は）そしてチャンネル名は、、、
は）リンクを楽しんでからのお楽しみだあああああ！！！！！
た）はあ⤴︎イタタタタタタたたたたたたたたた
は）頑張ろう！！！
た） 頑張ります頑張ります
は）頑張ろう
痛い痛い頑張ります！！！！！！！！！
ED　ED　ED　ED　ED　ED　ED
ED　ED　ED　ED　ED　ED
た〜〜〜〜〜たららら〜ら〜
たららら〜たららら〜ら〜たららら〜ら〜らら　たららた〜らら　つたったったったったたたたん